hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land that
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
not sure it's gonna go but let's see and
in the previous video you could see that
we hooked up all our electronics
for our solar system and making sure all
the wires are there but we don't have
any solar yet because we first need to
install the panels and we're going to do
that in this video
which means we're going to make a frame
put it on top of the container
it's going to be adjustable for the
angle of the sun and then at the end of
the video we connect everything and we
should have electricity
so first we have to get some metal and i
actually found a super cool
metal shop quite close by where they
sell
tubes profiles and you can cut them as
well so you do need to buy full length
so yeah time to get some metal
we have a lot of metal also a lot of
little scrap parts
of sheets some big machinery
to cut it all
you have a lot of tubes
it's my shopping list
super cool that he wrote down all the
things
[Music]
foreign
we have some great safety goggles
very crispy all right
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
so the tubes are now on the roof
sticking out on the back in the front
not sure how legal it is however that's
not my worry
the worry would be more that we go to a
bumpy downhill road
so it could easily shake off fall in my
front window i don't know
it's a short ride but bumpy how's it
going
they seem quite stable
so there the dirt road starts bumpy
here comes the scary part most
steep downhill
how's it going still there
ah
easy
all right so we have our material now
it's time to build first we need to chop
it
into the right dimension before we weld
it and we can do that we have a metal
chop saw
in the workspace however before we can
do it we need to do two things
one is the job size in there but i never
used it
because we didn't have electricity
before and in the last video we got a
generator which runs on tree face
but never tested it we only used a
single face so
i'm not sure how that's going to go
second thing these beams are
long six meters has same
same length as the container so they
don't fit in
and before we leave we wanted to make a
hole on the side of the container so we
could slide them in and chop them
but we never did because we thought it
might leak and transport
and things like that so we also need to
add that hole
so we can actually chop these
so we need to make a hole in that ball
on that height to make sure all the beam
can go outside if they're very long
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so now we have a little hole to cut big
beams also a great place for a break
because it's a
perfect cup holder but yeah now it's
time to
chop some metal
[Music]
found
[Music]
good
[Music]
okay so we cut all the metal to make the
frame we also
cut it some additional items like this
which we're going to use to clamp the
frame on the container
using those standardized holes that are
always in there
but first we're going to drill them
holes to mount the panels on
[Music]
[Music]
so all the holes are now drilled next up
we're gonna do welding
but unfortunately our own welder machine
doesn't work on the generator because
the amperage is too high
um but luckily the neighbor borrowed his
his stick welder
and so we could still weld it not super
experienced with it but i think should
be okay
i'm more worried about not having any
flat surface is just all wobbly grass
so yeah i hope the frame is going to be
[Music]
straight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so all the components are now
ready we have here
a big frame
these are the holders it's going to be
on the floor some mounting brackets
to put underneath the holders to attach
it to the container
the tubes that are gonna open and extend
to make sure we can adjust the
angle of the panel and a few other
mounting brackets
now originally i wanted to put it all
together here so you can just put it on
top of the container or disassemble it
and then put it back together there
but i realized it's very hard to do here
with a non-flat floor
to really see everything is aligned so i
think i'm going to do the final assembly
on the container itself
and i probably have to take it back
apart again to paint it
it's kind of annoying but at least then
i know it's going to fit
so time to go on the container
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we are making an adjustable frame
which means we can change the angle of
the frame according to the angle of the
sun
because the angle of the sun changes
throughout the year
so for instance in the summer the sun is
much more straight up and in the winter
the sun is much lower and having your
panel at the exact same
angle as the sun is more efficient and
to find the right angle you first need
to know the latitude of where you are in
the world so in our case we're at 40
degrees
and then the right angle for your summer
sun is you deduct 15 degrees
so at 25 degrees would be the right
angle for us in summer to get the sun
from straight up
and 55 degrees would be the angle
in winter because we add 15 degrees and
overall this gives like a three to four
percent efficiency
increase not that much but it's also not
that much extra work
to make once your panel adjustable and
you don't need to change
this every day it's just twice a year
that you do this
so it's not that much work so it seems
like an easy score for some efficiency
gains
alright so everything fits everything is
aligned and the hinges work
which is good wasn't worried about that
it was also quite hot up there in the
sun
but now it cooled down so we're gonna
take it off the container give it a
final paint job and then we're gonna
assemble it back on with all the panels
and stuff
and then we can hook it up and we should
have electricity
[Music]
final assembly here we have our frame
all our screws and nuts
and all the parts now putting it
together
so here you have a corner of the
container which is super solid
then this plate is going on top with the
hole in the middle
and then on the bottom we have this
bracket
it's going to come in the middle with
the back
bolt and not to tighten it together and
then it's very strong way to clamp the
frame
to the container
[Music]
okay moment of truth everything is wired
up solar panels coming in here
the only thing breaking the circuit is
the fuse box so if we
uh put this one on everything should
work so let's
see
that seems to work
no fire no explosions should be good
and the upside of electricity is that we
have a working fridge
so when it gets hot we can cool down and
just sit inside
although probably uh it's more useful
for vegetables
fruits to keep them longer but having a
fridge
is a big big plus another big upgrade is
that all our kitchen appliances work
and the other upside is we cannot
finally charge all our electronics
we could already charge some in our van
and the solar panels
but now we can really properly charge
all our batteries
for the chainsaw and the brush cutter so
we can do way more of that work
which is uh really needed as well
so that's cool but one thing i actually
want to show you on the computer
is the software behind the solar setup
because it's really nice to keep track
of your habits
so this is basically our system
in the previous video you can see the
actual electrical components and how we
wired them up
but this is just the schematics of it
and it's updated real time
so at the moment as we speak we're
generating 490 watts of electricity with
our solar panels
and the little blue dots you can see it
moving and some of it moves to
our battery to charge it which is
actually already 100
and some goes to the inverter which
converts the
48 volts into 230 volts
which means we can use it with our
normal appliances
so currently we use 370 watts which is
probably the fridge and some of these
things charging
um so this is real time what's going on
and the current temperature is 28
degrees which is important for us to
keep track of
for when it's getting too hot to make
sure it doesn't overheat
and then here you can see
the solar history so you can sort of
really keep track of uh
your solar habits and one is the
consumption is kind of interesting we
used 14 kilowatts so far
and the production is 20 kilowatt so
we're good there
battery is always at full capacity and
you have way more statistics behind it
in the end i think this would really be
more valuable if you use it for a long
time to really track your habits
there's also way more options underneath
everything i don't really
know this yet but i'll continue to
explore
all right so this is our final solar
setup mounted on the container
with adjustable angle for winter and
summer winter
summer i'll share the 3d model and
schematics of the entire setup later in
the project camp academy
so you can replicate it but i still need
to clean up the files so go actually to
discord if you want to help out with
that
and this is quite an important update
for us to set up base camp
having electricity now we can properly
use our tools
and the next big milestone is going to
be running water
[Music]
all right so that was this update a bit
lengthy but was also quite some work
i hope you like it it's very funny
if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
and yeah i think we're going to get some
sleep now
see you in the next video or you want to
use some electricity
just because we can we can sleep with
the lights on we will sleep with the
lights on
why not
you